Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David, P. Call me any time.
Here's a teacher who called in during
their lunch break. They have a student
who seems to have been the victim of serious
political disinformation. My guess would be
from the parents. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hi, David. I teach fifth grade
in the suburbs of Chicago, Illinois, and I needed
to call you. I'm on my lunch break because right
before lunch, one of my students raised his
hand. I called on him, probably thinking it
was a question about the material or going to the
bathroom or something like that. Sure. And in a
straight face said. Joe Biden belongs in prison.
And I just froze, it just froze in the classroom.
So it's an interesting experience I wanted
to share and maybe get your reaction,
maybe get your explanation of why.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I I don't know what
age this student was, but my guess is this is
not something the student learned in school,
but this is probably something the student is
hearing at home. And it's very, very sad, Alison.
You come from a conservative family. You might
say, Oh, Joe Biden's position on abortion doesn't
align with my families or whatever. But Joe Biden
belongs in prison for what crime? And that is one
of those signals. When you hear that, it's sort
of like when you would hear certain things about
said about Barack Obama where you go, that's not
a policy disagreement. You've fallen for really
serious weaponize this information, and it's a
sad thing that it's even hitting hitting kids.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We're going to talk about the Supreme Court
backing qualified immunity for police officers.
Really a big story with far reaching trickle-down
implications. We will look at Democrats
eyeing a carbon tax, a carbon tax after
Joe Manchin's opposition to the climate plan in
the reconciliation bill. And we are going to talk
about how Joe Biden is now trying to figure
out how can he quietly restart student loan
payments and why? Why quietly? While I think
you can probably guess why. We'll talk about
all of those stories on today's bonus Joe. Get
instant access by signing up at Join Pat Minkoff.